Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Today we will make a new episode of Challenge Pongfintiy
Let's see what kind of challenges you have come up with this time!
Thank you!
Now it's time to play with the silver play button!
Almost!
Oh look at that!
Beautiful!
And guys remember to subscribe
So we can reach 1 million
And turn this one gold
This is such a dangerous job!
Ok, so this is table tennis tennis
Tennis tennis table?
Alright, bring it on!
Jackpot!
Emil, I'm not playing against you anymore!
Nice!
Ok so we have added length
So we can hit hard
I know what you're trying!
Wow!
That's nice!
Thanks for watching guys!
Remember to subscribe here
And watch our previous episodes from there
Thank you!